sin importar quién gane el próximo
presidente de eeuu será el más longevo
elegido en la historia del país donald
trump nació el 14 de junio de 1946 en un
barrio rico de nueva york- al terminar
sus estudios se hizo cargo del negocio
de bienes raíces de su familia en la
década de los 80 su nombre que figura en
varios rascacielos se hizo sinónimo de
éxito financiero hoy varios escándalos
miraron su imagen brillante
[Música]
yo bailé nació en noviembre 20 de 1942
en una familia modesta de pensilvania
estudió en delaware donde fue elegido
senador en 1972 continuó en el cargo
hasta que fue electo como vicepresidente
de barack obama en 2008
donald trump nunca fue elegido en las
urnas antes de llegar a la casa blanca
su anfitrión del reality show el
aprendiz desde 2004 hasta 2015 lo que
fue la principal razón de su popularidad
entre los estadounidenses ha estado
casado tres veces y tiene cinco hijos
job aiden se volvió a casar en 1977
después de la muerte de su primera
esposa y su hija en un accidente
automovilístico perdió a otro de sus
hijos y es padre de dos el candidato
demócrata le gusta asistir a juegos de
béisbol y fútbol americano y juega
ajedrez en línea
mientras que el actual presidente
prefiere ver televisión durante varias
horas al día su otra gran pasión es el
golf paso 280 días en cursos de golf
desde el inicio de su mandato acumulo
una cuenta de 140.000 millones de
dólares para los contribuyentes